وصل وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستون الى
اسرائيل اليوم الاثنين في زياره هي
الثانيه له منذ بدايه الحرب الاسرائيليه
على قطاع غزه حيث سيجتمع باعضاء مجلس
الحرب في تل ابيب لبحث معالم مسار الحرب
واجراءات الانتقال الى المرحله التاليه
وقال مسؤول دفاعي رفيع يرافق اوستون خلال
جولته ان الوزير سيلتقي في اسرائيل الم
سيتلقى المستجدات حول تقييم الحكومه
الاسرائيليه تقدم المحرز في غزه ولفت
المسؤول الى ان وزير الدفاع الامريكي
سيطرح اسئله على المسؤولين الاسرائيليين
حول المعايير التي يضعونها بهدف الانتقال
الى المرحله
التاليه معنا من تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام الياس ماذا بوصول وزير الدفاع
الامريكي الى تل
ابيب عبد القادر هذه الزياره هي على قدر
كبير من الاهميه ليس فقط لان وزير الدفاع
الامريكي يصل الى تلي ابيب انما لانه
يرافقه ايضا رئيس اركان الجيش الامريكي
تشارلز براون وهذا يعني بان هذه المحادثات
لن تتعامل فقط مع السياسات العامه
الاستراتيجيه وتبادل اطراف الحديث مع
الجانب الاسرائيلي انما سوف تناقش تفاصيل
مهمه جدا في سير الحرب وفي سير المعارك
على الجبهات كافه بما في ذلك جبهه البحر
الاحمر والجبهه اللبنانيه ووصول رئيس
اركان الجيش الامريكي بصحبه لويد اوستن
تؤكد على ذلك على ان البحث سوف يكون
مستفيضا في كل التحركات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه وعلى الجبهات كافه بطبيعه
الحال ستبقى الجبهه الفلسطينيه وجبهه غزه
هي المسيطره وهي الاهم على اعتبار ان
اوستن يريد ان يسمع من الجانب الاسرائيلي
ما هو السقف الزمني لانهاء المعارك الكبرى
في قطاع غزه ومتى تعتقد اسرائيل بانها قد
تنجز هذه ال المرحله من مراحل الحرب وهي
وقف القتال الكبير وقف الضربات الجويه
والمدفعيه الكبيره ووقف الهجوم الكبير
وهنالك من يرجح ان هذه المعارك على الاقل
ربما تستمر حتى اواسط الشهر الاول من
السنه الجديده او حتى نهايه الشهر الاول
من العام الجديد وبعدها سوف يتم النقاش في
هذه الزياره ما هي المرحله الثانيه وكيف
ستبدو المرحله الثانيه بالنسبه للقتال في
داخل قطاع غزه وهذا ما ياتي لويد اوستن
حقيقه للاستماع اليه والمرحله الثانيه
ربما تتمثل في كيفيه القيام بعمليات
عسكريه محدوده النطاق من جانب اسرائيل بما
في ذلك اوستن يريد ان يؤكد على الضوابط
التي سبق واكدت عليها الاداره الامريكيه
في سياق جولات وزيارات لمسؤولين امريكيين
اخرين الى تلي ابيب واهم هذه الضوابط
تتعلق في استمرار فتح معبر رفح لتدفق
المعونات الطبيه والغذائيه والنفط وكذلك
التزام اسرائيل فيما يعرف بقوانين الحرب
والقوانين الدوليه والنقطه الثالثه تتعلق
بعدم اقتلاع الفلسطينيين من المناطق
الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه هذه هي اهم النق
الرئيسيه لكن واضح بان اوستن ربما يعلن
ايضا عن اعلان تحالف لمواجهه ايضا
الحوثيين في البحر الاحمر وهذه نقطه ربما
تكون هامه في اطار هذه الزياره